[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here it is it's the Mavic mini this
thing is so incredibly cute like I can't
even handle it and it's so light it is
so light in fact that you do not have to
register it with the FAA so that's one
of the newest drone laws is if you have
an unmanned aircraft that is more than
250 grams you have to make sure that you
register it to legally be able to fly it
so this is ironically 249 grams
it's crazy how small this is like it's
smaller than my iPhone 11 Pro max so the
next distance that this will fly with a
controller is two and a half miles and
it has a thirty minute maximum flight
time on just a single charge it has a
microUSB port for charging and it
supports 18 watt fast charging for
photos it's 12 megapixels and the max
resolution for video is 2.7 K so you can
shoot in 25 or 30 frames a second but if
you switch to the full HD you can shoot
in 1920 by 1080 25 30 at 50 and 60
frames a second it has both GPS and
downward sensors for vision positioning
so we can hover both indoors and
outdoors there's also some snap crop
cars which are best use indoors in case
you hit something I love DG eyes quick
shots much like other drones it has the
usual rocket droney circle and helix
camera moves it also has this newly
redesigned t GI fly app the viewing area
is 20% larger if you compare it with a
DJI go for app I feel like this drone is
really being aimed at beginners but if
you're an experienced drone pilot I
think this is gonna be super fun for us
this is the case I love this thing so
much because you can basically fit
everything in it you've got your drone
you've got your battery charger and the
controller but underneath of it you can
fit your cables and have some extra prop
guards I love this controller because
the joysticks are removable and this is
probably one of my favorite features the
TG I finally started integrating in the
past few versions of their drone
controllers this makes it so much easier
for storage this is a battery charger
which out of all the things the DJI has
ever made like I've really never have
that many negative things to say but
this battery charger is so incredibly
difficult to get the batteries out of
like am i doing something wrong I don't
understand the one thing that the
batteries out you can get 30 minutes of
flight time
[Music]
I just want to go on record thing that
right now this is probably my favorite
drone to date the size of the quality
and even flying it like it was super
smooth it's not too windy out today but
even so like I was flying really quickly
I was in sport mode alright let's go
somewhere else
[Music]
I'm gonna test out the cinah smooth
feature this isn't something that's new
but I really usually never fly like this
clay like to fly quick and fast and in
sport mode you can make big movements
but it doesn't allow you to actually go
that fast so it keeps everything very
cinematic and very smooth hence the name
sit a smooth so we're back from Catalina
and I've got all of my indoor
accessories to play with we've got the
Mavic mini DIY creative kit and I have
my prop guards already on I just did a
quick test flight just to see how it
flew around the house and it was pretty
awesome
so these prop guards just snap on fairly
easy so they just go on each side to
protect your propellers you will
definitely hit things in your house like
that's unless you're like an incredible
pilot I don't even care you're probably
gonna hit something because you can't
really see up or down when you're flying
so I can have two hitting the ceiling
because I was sitting downstairs and I
flew it upstairs so the only view that
you have obviously is from your
controller let's open this up I really
don't know what this is gonna look like
we've got some crayons markers these are
probably markers I wouldn't imagine we
could keep you crayons to decorate the
faceplate with we've got a wide variety
of colors if you've got a little blue or
red a black and a green oh they're like
little sticker
in school so you can color it it also
has some blank ones I mean look how cool
that's gonna look let me just do a
really quick illustration just to see
how these markers write on it because
honestly that's one of the things that I
would want to know if I was watching
this video I would writes actually
pretty nice my review of the markers is
actually I would say probably like an 8
out of 10 but we got a tres all the
colors know it's terrible
it's disgusting that's absolutely
terrible I juiced Eton I just didn't I
mean this is honestly this is
embarrassing but I'm gonna put it on my
drone so I think we have to clean our
drone first probably should have turned
it off so sure to save battery but the
battery on this thing was amazing the
whole time we're in Catalina I was
really surprised at how much battery
life we ended up getting with this oh
god I'm shaking I do much caffeine oh
okay oh oh I've messed up okay you guys
get the point it's beautiful okay let's
take off I'll take off right here why
not so right now we have another shoot
happening as well we're setting up for
something really cool we're shooting a
bunch of really cool 180 videos so this
entire place has just been I mean
there's just stuff everywhere look it's
a mess you guys will see very shortly
[Music]
I'm really thoroughly enjoying this so
far
let's go for oh my gosh man there we are
this looks like an actual hurricane has
gone through this place
[Music]
radhiya pretty quickly for this house
so hey it would be this way
right
laundry oops they hit the wall it's okay
[Music]
this is handling really well inside
[Music]
Oh God
[Music]
okay I gotta go up whoopsies whoops
oh we've hit some stuff I know it hi
there's Jenna okay that's definitely
help taking it on sport mode
Jeb is having an unboxing here okay
let's go back downstairs
Sparky
I don't know how that was
I'm gonna fly it really fast in here
okay ready okay I'm just gonna hit
forward it's gonna go real fast
I hit it really hard
[Music]
okay I don't know what was happening
upstairs so that's the first look at the
new maverick mini and honestly I love
this thing so much now the quality that
you're getting from this is obviously
not gonna be bad of the Matic pro or
anything like that because it's not 4k
it's a smaller sensor and this is
something that is a little more geared
towards beginners but all in all if I'm
traveling and I just want to get some
cool drone shots on a hike or something
like that this is great I love that it
has these prop guards I was able to fly
really well inside and I think if you're
looking for a cool small little tiny
drone that will get you some cool aerial
shots like this is it like I don't think
that there's anything else out there
like this right now and especially
because it's DJI it's like they're
software everything no there's nothing
else out there like this and I'm hyped
that's the end of the video so I'll see
you guys later a link in the description
[Music]